we talk a lot on the show about how
representation matters but what if that
representation is so deeply offensive
that it's worse than not being
represented at all i'll explain in a
segment called how did we get here
[Music]
recently marvel comics introduced a new
character named princess matoka now if
that sounds familiar it's because matoka
is the birth name of an indigenous woman
most of us know as pocahontas now i know
what you're thinking what a great
opportunity to show a historic native
woman for the complicated resourceful
brave person that she was well instead
they did this
wow yeah first that's super racist
second it's very confusing to literally
anyone who has seen a woman in her
underwear
now in case you're wondering if this was
drawn by a man let me point out that
there are zero bra straps and she's
wearing gold pasties and yeah she's
holding up a metal orb entirely with the
strength of her breasts
apparently this comic is set in an
alternate universe where native women
exist but gravity does not
now if it's not clear to you why that
character is upsetting people let's take
a minute and decolonize your
understanding
native women have been hyper-sexualized
throughout american history and the
consequences have been devastating
according to the department of justice
native american women are two to three
times more likely than women of any
other race to experience violence
stalking or sexual assault and that is
terrifying the only thing native women
should experience three times more than
other races is compliments about their
incredible community and nation building
skills then
good job good job now instead of
focusing on this offensive depiction of
matoka let's learn about the reality now
many of you are probably familiar with
her mostly from disney's pocahontas a
movie about a native woman who falls in
love with an english guy named john
smith saves his life has a close
personal friendship with a raccoon
of course almost none of that turns out
to be true i mean i'm not ruling out the
raccoon part they're adorable and they
seem like great listeners i don't know
who her friends were but in reality
matuka was around 10 years old when she
met john smith and he was almost 30 so
instead of this it would have looked a
bit more like this
so
unlike the disney movie there was never
any kind of romance between matoka and
john smith because and this is important
ew
also in every portrait of john smith he
has this facial hair and whether it's
the 1600s or 2022 i think we all would
have clocked that mustache as something
you don't let around young children
so
disney was wrong about the romance and
the age although that's definitely not
disney's biggest age-related lie
i'm just gonna say it there's no way
chip is mrs pot's son
here is what she looks like when she
turns back into a human that lady is in
her late 60s easy now you're telling me
she has a kid chips age
what kind of secrets are you hiding in
that teapot mrs potts
the movie also says that matoka snuck
food to john smith and even risked her
own life to stop her tribe from
executing him but it turns out those
parts probably aren't true either first
of all according to the indigenous site
indian country today when the colonists
didn't grow enough food for themselves
john smith actually stole food from the
tribe by holding a gun to the heads of
village leaders so natives like matoka
likely gave john smith food in the same
way that cashier gives all his money to
a gyneski mask
and as for matoka saving john smith from
execution well historians say that
probably didn't happen either in fact
many deny that he was going to be
executed at all
that's right native historians have
called out the lies just like i'm going
to call out anyone who thinks john smith
is hotter than coco
you are wrong and i will fight you
you're you're wrong and i'm gonna fight
you john smith looks like if x body
spray was a person
he's the human embodiment of crushing a
beer can on your forehead
he's the third to last guy on every
season of the bachelorette and you know
what else john smith's bangs are the
mcdonald's logo
there
that's right i said it so why is it that
many of us have learned this incorrect
history well because america likes
stories about native women that make it
look like they welcome western culture
and live happily ever after the actual
story of matuka is a devastating one
according to native accounts she was
kidnapped raped by colonists and died
before the age of 21. and no matter how
many adorable raccoons you add that
story sucks but it's the truth so for
just a second let's bring back this
picture now the writer actually
apologized for his depiction of princess
matuka and vowed to change the name and
the design after he was called out on
twitter by native comic lovers but i
don't want to focus on the writer of
that comic i do want to talk about why
it matters because continuing to
hyper-sexualize indigenous women in
fiction can lead us to ignore their
abuse in real life according to a 2016
report from the national institute of
justice more than four out of five
indigenous women reported they had been
the victim of violence and 96 percent of
them described their attacker as
non-native american
even worse those attackers often can't
be prosecuted that's because a 1978
supreme court case called olefant versus
sukuamish indian tribe decided tribes
have limited authority to prosecute
non-tribal citizens that leaves open
a legal loophole where in some cases
non-natives can enter a reservation
commit violence and not be held
responsible which is insane it's like if
i went to florida and kicked a bunch of
people in the shins and then i got away
with it because i don't live in florida
that's not right i should be held
accountable or i'll just keep kicking
poor tarik now here's the thing we as
artists and consumers have to be extra
careful in how we treat native people
because our country has not been
theorefen show was filmed on the
traditional land of the lenape people's
past and present and we honor with
gratitude the land itself and the people
who have stewarded it throughout the
generations it is our duty
it's our duty to make sure indigenous
women are depicted with care and
integrity and more importantly make sure
they get a chance to depict themselves
that means supporting native women in
everything from writers rooms to
boardrooms it means donating to the
national indigenous women's resource
center it means supporting positive
native representation by watching shows
like reservation dogs and rutherford
falls
and speaking of support it also means
making damn sure they get all the bra
straps they need this has been how do we
get here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you